viewer discretion is advised I'm honest
cops is filmed on location with the
brave strong women of law enforcement
all suspects are innocent until proven
guilty in a court of law
315 confirmed suspect isn't 302 over all
right so we got two warrants out for
this guy's RSO he's not coming out so
we're gonna have to extract him
3:15 correction suspect is in 301 over
bad girl bad girl what you gonna do what
you gonna do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's called 200 episodes that's right
don't do that I don't like it when
people do the wus you're not on a five
doesn't six flags as soon as it did that
every credit really when people when
you're at the bar someone's like hey
we're doing shots and well wow you're
just an idiot I don't like you there's
no there's no blossom like me either
all right producing with me in video
studio as always as Jared who is not gay
follow him on Twitter at not gay Jared
me @s crowd or send us your comments
your thoughts your photo shops whatever
else dude another episode
I'm sure these interesting things I
fulfill my league operations general
conclusions we go good enough that's
Jean Morgan juniors hey Gerald we've got
a little bit of Nicolas folliage
champagne from Courtney aka the Dark
Lord of the North West we have a great
I'm surprised cause I know I know that
yes but we just found out yesterday that
Gerald was colorblind and we have no
idea before so when we send or easy
sanitized me we create a show back we
have color coded like a link is blue we
have this is the headline from the
articles missus rough and what do you
think when you do Burleigh of Singh
silver and gold does just put you into
an uncontrollable rage great guest today
we have Owen Benjamin got a little deep
got a little bit Lefors little number we
have Jim Norton who I love one of my
favorite guest one of my favorite
comedians out there and of course we
have Clint Howard who's insane so that's
good a lot of fun but Howard Clint
Howard is he's everything wind I will
say this off air he's everything that
you would expect him to be and we have a
bunch of news to get to you by the way
quick mention hey John McCain we're
sorry to hear about what's going on with
Senator John McCain I know it's gotta be
rough for his family and you know the
thoughts and prayers think but sorry we
hope the guy recovers I know it's pretty
bad answer yes he is about it so there
you go John McCain speaking of the
complete opposite of a man who we
respect and John McCain Lena Dunham
joins the cast of American Horror Story
this is just announced the headline yes
she so you know American horror story's
actually it is a great example of TV has
come up so much the quality of its
pretty disturbing I don't really watch
it but the make defines have Awards for
makeup or costume design and she
actually posted a picture at or
Instagram of her allegedly long for our
transformation in makeup and wardrobe
it's uncanny they are brilliant that's
like the firework at the beginning of
the show that never gets off the ground
it's true
we tried saying that although I've never
lived in American Horror Story I wish I
had so that oh yeah abortion there you
go there's a new new global plastic
study ah enough plastic to literally
bury Manhattan two times over
researchers with this new global study
have declared that over nine point 1
billion tons of plastic have been made
since 1950 it sounds like a lot yes
considered a lot of you lookin sitting
at a crisis others see a silver lining
in the ability to literally bury
Manhattan do times over
better yet great one and a half times
then work your way to Brooklyn all the
fixes are gonna be buried and then we
can move on to sixteen gear bicycles yes
there we go so that's that's that's
correct 9 point 1 billion tons of
plastic made since 1950 wow that's a lot
of lievable amounts research estimate
that 9 percent has gone toward water
bottles 2 percent to medical technology
and the remaining eighty nine percent
into Nicki Minaj so that's what joke is
obvious out but like you were saying a
lot of plastic plastic going into
bottling yeah so that 35 percent of the
increase I think is in like water
bottles in places that didn't water now
you know have water jerks so yeah I know
it seems like that should be a good
thing yes go over to Zambia you're like
oh five meet like now can you use the
Nalgene recycle because every time we
fill up the knowledge in the river we
get AIDS
it's full of estrogen can do that we can
gather that it's not even BPA free I
really could put it alive I believe
microwave
Indian I don't know I give you accent
hey Jay Simpson is soon to be a free man
oh this was just announced I was
trending everywhere I will say this the
guy did nine years this is he was
obviously doing the time for a crime
unrelated to killing two people so as
much as we don't like it the justice
system does have to have to play itself
a good thing and his quarter correction
officer he actually described OJ's
prison life as a cruise with barbed wire
that's how he described it so they
obviously weren't big fans of the
treatment they're an OG agreed saying
that he actually he loved the prisons
great gym three square meals a day free
cable and of course the stabbing room
was one of his favorites which almost
seems as though a prison is encouraging
poor behavior it almost seems that way
like you think like maybe like they
could reform them a little little better
it seems irresponsible it does sort of
stabbing room with OJ Simpson so John
boyega we talked about this on
yesterday's show from Oakland members
John boyega complained that there
weren't enough black people on Game of
Thrones No
so the freights frontier Game of Thrones
creators just today announced their next
show confederate set in the world where
slavery still actually exists
[Music]
you know that's not what I meant
said John boyega on Twitter it's
trending everywhere it's set the
internet ablaze for a multitude of
different reasons some people think this
is great because it's an opportunity for
black people in Hollywood some people
think why do I always have to play
slaves I understand and DeRay is
actually just complaining already
claiming cultural appropriation which I
can actually see oh and it almost seems
shameless that almost does someone seems
like they meant to pouch pouch there
Gerald alright
I saw Planet of the Apes by the way the
new dead of the apes yeah and when I saw
the vest I couldn't stop laughing the
theater people were wondering when
laughing hysterically
DeRay let's play this joke is when you'd
made that transition that bet that was
not too smooth this segue wink
don't know where a was complaining he
appropriated his blue blue vest and so
now when you're saying they appropriate
of my blue vest I'm a black lives matter
activist and this is my vest and you see
it on an ape I just I just about peed
myself in the theater I was at a moment
you were supposed to be really touching
you know what's a monkey with the
Winchester you ruined it for everybody
in the theater yeah you should go
Michael Richards to point something like
that out I was let it was like Robert De
Niro in Cape Fear it was that funny okay
so in the news we just talked about this
yesterday Chris Hemsworth came out and
said that it is time for a females James
Bond that's that's the slogan for 2016
and 2017 it seems now it's just it's
time what is Hillary Clinton need to be
at it's time for a female president why
does someone who just lopped off their
penis why don't they get it's time why
don't we eat an iconic male character -
it's time for a female James Bond
so here - to take that on is louder with
crowd favorite and comedian I think we
have them on the line by Skype is Owen
Benjamin Owen well Steven in the game I
wrote a song today about our little
buddy Chris Hemsworth who said it's
about time but there's a female James
Bond well it's about time little little
Chris Hemsworth or Hemings Worth James
Bond would be like you can have a female
action star but you can't be female
James Bond maybe you can I'm so
open-minded I wrote a song about it it's
about female James Bond
it's beautiful instead of develo 7gb
double-oh-seven
seven cents
[Music]
her passport would have a snapchat
filter and she'd always keep changing
her mind about dinner
[Music]
Q would be a Queenie gay guy instead of
bringing sachets they complain about
their frenemies
[Music]
she can't keep a secret she's got like
nine blocks that fortunately nobody
reads
[Music]
she's got Jane bond but she's open to
hyphenation it always says she needs a
vacation
[Music]
Jane bond can't drive when she's in
Saudi Jane pond
she's pretty hot but insecure about her
body
orders a martini shaken not stirred the
blacks out cuz she forgot to eat dinner
[Music]
and five-foot 1/100 pedals not strong or
fast and each sports because she doesn't
get wide there has to be a winner I say
have to be a winner
[Music]
she's hoping to hide the nation
she's bond James Bond and always in need
of a vacation
she's bond Jeanne pond can't drive when
she's sent to Saudi
[Music]
and she shouldn't exist
ever
[Music]
yeah it's amazing how smart you have to
be to create something that stupid
yes it's just a brilliantly classically
trained pianist I remember he was out he
was sitting there with that what's his
name Pete Holmes who was insulting him
for being kind of silly with its comedy
yeah yeah you know I'm a real artist and
man he was like well hon this is have
you heard that he starts playing like
that Beethoven a symphony let you tell
jokes about your small penis so Thank
You Owen Benjamin by the way you can
watch more of his stuff on youtube at
Owen Benjen Owen Benjamin comedy and
sees tour dates huge pianist comment
thank you for the enunciation alright
last try before have to get to our
guests this was posted on Facebook by
some people in Essex I think in tandem
with police officers after a massive
knife turning programme and they said
they tagged this only cowards carry
which is one of it I don't know about
you have heard this a lot have you heard
this rule ago yeah you have to construe
curious because you're insecure this is
one of the delusions of the left this is
a great example I truly do feel as to
how delusional they are it's you know if
you were really tough then you wouldn't
need to carry a gun or no poor food it's
so stupid because it's someone who
clearly has never been in an altercation
yeah it's someone who's never been in a
physical confrontation in their life
this is this is why this man it's the
same reason were they like Walsh
Charlize Theron could kick your ass cuz
I saw her doing the stunts no she
couldn't no she couldn't you're not
living in the real world just like if
you think someone is a coward because
here's if you are the toughest biggest
baddest dude on the block okay and it is
an anemic AIDS victim and you're in a
fight and he either has a gun or a knife
you have no chance doesn't matter how
brave you are I am no coward
no one can defeat me for I am strong and
fast
by the way they try to hire an actual
strong man no one would do the show we
just so glycerin will do I apologize
only nice what if someone what if
someone else is carrying a knife yeah
what if someone else has a gun which by
the way criminals usually do oh you
should just again you handle hand hang I
don't
most criminals are in for a fair fight
and one thing even the study after study
I'll be all don't really study after
study has shown that even trained police
officers have huge problems with knife
attacks it's pretty much impossible to
defend against a knife attack
Yoma so that's what's something you
learn about commonly in and concealed
carry courses about the 21 foot rule and
how fast someone with a knife can just
mess you up right and I couldn't find
this this study we didn't have enough
time did if there was one with a chalk
knife and someone out there if you could
send it to me I had a friend was in the
police force he trained actually police
officers and he talked about how they
took I think 100 police officers had a
chalk knife and they didn't take out the
knife until they were stabbing somebody
which is what usually happens in
altercations only 80 of them well only
80 of them were stabbed and dead before
they realized wow 20 of them realized a
knife was being pulled and only one was
able to actually do anything and get
away so this idea of disarmed you're
gonna Stevens you're not living in
reality and this is the issue with
today's modern left they don't deal in
reality and by the way saying only
cowards carry the left doesn't
understand this is unbelievably
discriminatory toward women absolutely
exactly because they stand to gain the
most amongst everyone in caring let's
bring up those stats and then wreck
their only chance at not being raped or
assaulted as caring I do you look at
look at that with a gun their percent of
completed meaning the assault completed
against them point nine percent with a
knife point when using weaponless
physical force 30 percent that's 30
times and that's also what I've talked
about how knife crime at is actually
often worse than gun crime yeah that's
right there you go all I was only 0.9%
with a gun 0.0% with a knife I've talked
about this with muggings actually people
tend to get hurt and more with muggings
that involve a knife and that's because
someone aims a gun at you you're not
screwing around
alright fine they're either gonna shoot
you or take your
so you're making up your mind if someone
mugs you with a knife they often get
into a scuffle and someone gets cut
regardless yeah so this is important to
and this is important all of this you
look at these stats they stand the most
to gain a 30% increased chance of
getting went 300 0 percent to 30 percent
older I don't know number because
contrary to the virtue signaling on
Facebook and the county of Essex rapes
and Essex have actually gone up
significantly over a hundred percent in
the last year's and violent crime in
England and Wales has gone up 19 percent
so rape is going up violent crime is
going up and this is why this is
important it's time for a female James
Bond and people listen no one really
cares about the fact that it's a female
James Bond it's just this idea now that
it's time this arbitrary it's time only
cowards carry well why are you saying
that because weapons are bad therefore
if you carry one you're bad you're a
weapon that's not the reality that we
live in
so rather than virtue signal the only
cowards carry we know statistically if
the left really wanted to help women
they wanted to fight rape culture the
best thing they could do is give women
guns and training yeah exactly
seriously it would save a lot of lives
it would save a lot of lives
particularly make them safer it would
make police lives easier how many times
are you at least talking about it's like
it's just it's just it's a scene I
shouldn't go around as much and this is
this is kind of we talked about this
it's it's the point of stating a
falsehood just because it goes along
with your narrative like yesterday this
story we covered it just Caitlyn Jenner
stuns in this dress and then it was a
picture of Caitlyn Jenner looking like a
necklace bearded lady walking out and
you're going on a second that's that's
not that you wrote words but that's not
how your why don't we like let's just
say some words to combat how all the
things we don't like and wish were not
true that our true yeah we do you see
the stack of those knives the hell's
going on in Essex so they use not well
it's true by the way gun crime has gone
up too so it's not like
we'll take the lesser of two evils now
you get both so the virtue signalling
and the false reality of the left pushes
you know it's annoying when it's Caitlyn
Jenner stuns or Caitlyn Jenner's woman
it annoys us it's annoying when it's
Charlize Theron at five foot eight 120
pounds can kick any guy's ass because
she took some stunt coordination classes
it's annoying but when it comes to
creating an alternate reality and
proactively lying about it to protect a
narrative and involves women being able
to protect themselves it's no longer
annoying it's actually fatal and we've
seen that happen in the real world so I
would rather read some headlines that
say criminal thwarted and stabbed or
shot by a woman and left an alleyway
than woman raped and there's a several
thousand percent greater chance that the
ladder would be the case at the left
head their way
hope you enjoy it Essex will be back
with Jim Norton
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh are you watching that louder with
Crowder again is it 9:00 p.m. Eastern on
a weekday then of course I'm watching
let her play Josephina with demo club
member why can't you get back you just
pay full price
I did pay full price of $69 Anjali for
daily content as a student Josephine
you're not even a student dammit won't
understand my own damn why I got my GED
I studied culinary arts Bridgetown why
you I wouldn't even finish I also have a
bring fountain tempo karate which is an
arch something you don't know about
animal [ __ ] Phoenix I signed up for
the merrily wasted man you know I hate
spam
[Music]
all right that was elevate because we
were trying to elevate the show now
after strip after this first segment
really have our next guest on funny if
we had him on the first and we didn't
know I guess what the crossover was with
with people who watch the show oh my
gosh I love Jim absolute but I realized
a lot of young people who watched a
young didn't realize that Jim used to be
heavier and we talked about that this
week on the show he's one of the few
comedians who shed the weight away for
such a long amount of time an entire
audience has been introduced to him they
have no idea know it anyway horrible
introduction but his specialist mouth
full of shame on Netflix and of course
he else's show with Sam Roberts on
Sirius XM is it called the Jim in Sam
show Jim Norton Sam Roberts Jim Norton
Simon Sam Jewish yeah there's no toilet
flushing sounds and Colleen win the
contest hold the car see how long you
can hold your bladder we have that
Montreal a morning show someone died
because they actually what they would
put them in water and see how long they
could hold their Pierre P and so just
hold in the router and then just fell
over and died it's called a hold your
Wie for a week they were doing it I want
to say that was on the west coast like
Portland OR Seattle myself that could be
wrong okay but it was contest they were
running for whatever the Wii game
controller is that's it hold you reefer
away in forever cuz now you can't do any
eating or drinking contests at all
because that one lawsuit yeah
where's he a pack refer I usually work
with pac-man frogs you put them in a
bath of water those poison themselves
really yeah no joke
also they eat their friends yeah we're
still the worst job ever everyone can
ascend if they had a worst job now yeah
yeah that is that's and what a way to go
that is got to be unbelievably painful
okay Jim we covered this on the website
this week I don't know how much feedback
you've gotten from it but it was one of
our most popular stories of the week
probably because people just loved how
quickly and succinctly
you you put a stop to Reeboks bullcrap
so we'll put this up they put up their
tweet saying in case you're wondering
when it's okay to basically tell woman
she's beautiful and pretty much the
answer for those who are listening it's
it's no never appropriate and then you
responded with this which I thought was
perfect thank you about free virtuous
message and when it's appropriate to cut
and it's just uh
tone with a woman's ass of course
implication is that she's beautiful
first off did you have that at the ready
were you like please Reebok make this
mistake or did you just retrieve it from
memory I leave whatever company does
something like that it just annoys me
it's like don't moralize you dopes
because I know that you've probably done
something that's exactly the opposite of
what we're trying to scold Trump for
doing right so whatever accompany more
lies it's pretty easy to catch them
being foolish it's not hard well
especially with Reebok I mean when you
think about it that their entire
athletic product line is designed to
making women feel beautiful or to
perform or to train in their clothing in
order to become beautiful they are
effectively selling the business of
beauty but what point do you think they
thought this was a good idea and did
they respond to you at all they didn't
respond to me no I think that again it's
like an echo chamber people live in and
they hear only people talking the way
they kind of feel so I think they were
probably shocked that they got any bad
blowback at all from it but like it
wasn't even about the politics or what
the president said if they had named a
few other places where it's okay to
compliment somebody I would say okay
that's just how they feel it was
inappropriate for a public figure right
the fact they couldn't think of any
other time to do it except for what it's
like shut up stop your sneakers and
don't act like that's oh we're trying to
sell those sneakers to the women so we
show them how great will make their ass
shut up no well even then they're hoping
that other women will say hey your ass
looks beautiful how'd you do it the
sneakers at some point it comes back
it's the circle of ass mice's yeah this
wasn't for those I should have prefaced
this it was after the president said
made some comments down being beautiful
do you ever tell women they're beautiful
like here's why would you say what's
about with you I don't know a good way
to ever tell a woman they look good
because they've lost weight that's one
thing I'm always uncomfortable with
because you're trying to compliment them
but you have to insult their previous
self how do you handle you just say
you're beautiful or do you just mount
them I'll usually say that you look hey
you look great
I don't mind telling someone they lost
weight because even though it is like
saying like wow no longer big it's still
a compliment though and when people
compliment you on losing weight you know
that you probably needed to lose it
you don't feel insulted you're like oh
they're right I'm so happy I did this so
y'all just say hey you look great and
the fact that people got pissed off at
Trump for that it's a-okay maybe it's
weird for the president to say that but
the intention wasn't to be lecturer so
he really was just trying to compliment
somebody and if you complement somebody
in a way that is deemed clumsy or not
perfect if you're still trying to
compliment them that people shouldn't
act like you were sitting there trying
to dump something into their drink again
the past exactly it's not exactly the
Bill Cosby a fencing hey you look good
and it's entirely dependent on the
attractiveness of the male let's be
honest if the guys tribute says we were
actually going to do a hidden camera on
this but the guy dropped out you know
who nah kid you're a big fat pig of a
guy we were agreed to be the foil then
dropped out we wanted to have a
good-looking guy and then an ugly guy
just tell women hey you're beautiful see
how they react I can say my personal
life that particularly as a young
teenager with full of pimples doesn't go
so well the reaction is different and it
also depends on the person saying how
the people here in it feel about that
person right people listening like that
person then they'll see if someone did
this like I was try to be nice to
compliment
you know like Obama was talking about
some a woman who's an attorney general
whatever she was and I didn't think
there's anything wrong with him going
like you know she's the best looking
truck whatever Attorney General or you
know whatever her [ __ ] to one and that
was fine but if a guy they don't like
politically says it he's incredible it's
just it's arbitrary so I was actually
going to ask you next if there were
times where Obama complimented a woman's
looks and I've got to imagine that's the
case gotta be some point it didn't mean
he was just joking around and being
friendly he wasn't trying to be a creep
so it wasn't a big deal and either
people just take it when they don't like
the guy and they make a big deal about
it I had a guy do that at dinner once
when I was he was meeting my wife at
some point it was it was my wife's
friend's husband all right so I go
here's my beautiful bride you know that
whatever my better half that always the
joke is like I'm ugly she's attractive
it's all this time it's an icebreaker
and the guy was like oh yeah cuz I
couldn't possibly talk about her about
her brains all right something like that
about her injured like he said that and
I was like you do you dick first off
your
you're not only self-important and
nobody likes you immediately in this
social gathering but you just like my
wife is not happy that you said that
because for my wife it is a complement
of Phil oh yeah she looks great and the
guy actually went out of his way to do
this and I got another way to word the
guy you said hey oh there's your better
half and is like oh what'd he say about
me
I lost a friend over that literally one
of my best friend
that guy who said that he was just um
bag and here's what he ate he's a white
knight and he's trying to white knight
your wife from a compliment you're
giving her and it's like shut because
you understand the social context we
people just say stuff like that we know
that yeah we yeah I mean I I'm not I'm
not enough of a [ __ ] that I'd marry
someone who I feel like is an idiot I
have to go home to him in it there's
some guys who feel that way I lost a
friend over that too on the flip side I
won't I won't use his name either
because hopefully can be repaired in
time but it was my dad who actually made
the comment hey hey wow she's she's
gorgeous what's she doing with you
ha ha ha you know corny old dad joke and
I got a letter written out like an email
as to we just feel you don't respect a
relationship saying that you know she's
out of my league if you wrote you a
whole letter he's clearly a trainee in
hiding yeah I mean it's just it's what
low self confidence must you have to be
affectionate Berkley no it was a
centennial Regional High School in
Montreux which is just as bad because
there we have far far left liberals and
then far left liberal separatists like
there isn't even a backlash it's just
their back lashing against well hold on
a second now we have taxpayer-funded
abortion at will what else do we
campaign for I don't know sex changes
now let's put someone in jail for not
marrying two homos what can we do we
need to know further pretty good and
there's all these things you need to be
fixed with there are social changes
people can't find as hard for social
changes if they're happening so then
they hip they're like sorry I'm taking
the language because special interest
group only they always need a function
they always need to exist otherwise
they'll go away right yeah I was like
Owen Benjamin says we're so bored 2017
we've resorted to cutting off our own
dicks yeah and then and then examining
the social consequences yeah okay
speaking of which I don't want to put in
a spot
I did ask Jim before on there because I
know comedians never want to ever pit
them against one another
obviously Trevor Noah is a comedian but
we've had this conversation before name
only or where we going with here stop it
not gay Jared we need to let Jim have a
fair shake at this this was him on the
view and I've talked about this and I
need you and I have mostly agreed but
had some slight disagreements and absent
I think your generation a little bit
like you and Nick DiPaolo have somewhat
of a blind spot and it means in a
complementary way because even the
people with whom you disagree with
politically in your generation you never
wanted to silence each other it was okay
I think that guy's a dick
um that couldn't be less of the case
with this new crop of comedians 25 and
under they are trying to close the door
behind them and this is a clip knock
each other make sure Jim can see this
from the view Trevor Noah then I want to
get your thoughts things the comedian
said back in the day we're not leaving
the sense of at all
I mean I'm we got away with stuff in
those days that we could never get away
with you know what to be honest with you
I think it's good why I genuinely think
it's good I won't lie as a comedian I
look back and I go this things I said
that I shouldn't have been saying like
we're progressing we're moving forward
these things that we said about women
that we shouldn't have been saying these
things that were saying no I think there
were things that we shouldn't have been
saying and if you look at the progress
if you look at what you what you're
trying to do as a comedian essentially
what I know I'm trying to do is I'm
trying to move forward I'm trying to
think progressively okay okay I can't
take any more odd Jim your thoughts I
don't want to taint them well you know
what if he says things I should have
been saying that's fine like you know
couple things oh sure that goes too hard
but when it comes to allowing people to
say stuff there can be especially the
struggle comes to a really an impressive
place that he understands what it's like
to live in a place where your parents
couldn't even walk on the same side of
the street right so before just going
socially should not we do not talk about
the government he's not talk about the
government but he is talking about how
people should help how boy cut he's
supporting boycotts and basically people
getting out the outrage machine he does
support that because my job is Akemi
his job may be to be progressive mine is
not to forward a political agenda Rob
mine is to be funny and to be honest
sometimes that does have a political
agenda but it's not you know how fast
the Republicans drawbacks the Democrats
like for me my job is and comedians to
be honest and funny but again he may see
his job differently I just don't see my
job as needing to be progressive or
conservative it's just gotta be funny
and that is kind of crazy to me where he
got like his baseline is just assumed if
you look at what we're supposed to do as
comedians we're supposed to be
progressive like that's that's the depth
of job definition he said it as though
no one around him around his social
circle goes wait what hold on Trevor you
might not want to go out in public with
that one he assumes that's the baseline
not even to push a political message or
to affect change but to be progressive
is my job like that's on his resume
that's concerning to me yeah I mean I
don't need to be progressive and also
hard being progressive doesn't mean
taking away other people's voices or
boycotting people because they have a
voice because they've sucked right
there's a lot of people like they suck
as people but they're allowed to say
whatever they want I never want a comic
to get in trouble I didn't want anyone
to get in trouble for saying things I'm
a big boy I don't like what you said
I'll just don't hate you and I like what
you said how do you make that do you
make the DeNiro face when you say it hey
I don't just seems like it's your
natural set point when you when you use
the phrase have you felt it changed
though like in recent years obviously
not only have you been doing stand-up
comedy but then you were on Fox you know
with the red eye and then that that's
not there anymore but then you know
you've been doing kind of a you've been
at the front of X XM radio and
podcasting have you seen the wave of the
backlash kind of going away people
thrown off political correctness whereas
some people I would I would say Trevor I
know you like Trevor but I would say are
trying to slam that door behind them and
they're taking part in the witch-hunt
that's what's crazy to me there are a
lot of comedians taking part in the
witch-hunt now and they never think they
are it's almost like people's motives
are good they want it they want to
create a place that they think hey this
is a safe place for people I think
people would politically correct like
I'm trying to go why do they think this
well because of that all
people some of them really believe in it
or Eliza so what is their motive I think
a lot of them really feel like hey this
is the best way to do it and I just
don't think it is because it's like the
matter how unoffensive you think you're
being hey if you're for gay marriages
you're a very politically correct person
but that opinion just in itself offends
a lot of people in the country so now
you not want to be able to say you're
for gay marriage because that's deemed
offensive by a large segment apart
it's a no-win game so you just got to
don't look everybody can say what they
want to say and trust the rest of us to
just know what we feel is right and
wrong I totally forgot what your
question is no it's fine it totally
worked it was actually was it was very
philosophical which was what are we
gonna say I think what part Trevor's
promise he's so out of touch he thinks
because he mentions his example is like
Oh to not do a fat joke is actually to
in his mind to be edgy that's pushing
the edge to step outside the sphere of
fat jokes he doesn't realize actually
whoa be edgy is to be anti political
correctness which you know toss a Muslim
joke in your thing ever that would be
edgy if he wants to be really actually
edgy yeah he is his definition of what
is comedic ly edgy just baffles me when
you watch the clip that's one thing that
I do and I'll expand on that and Jim you
can this is kind of your millyar you
know right you did the nasty show we
talked about their Just for Laughs they
would love it if the nasty shell could
do this dirty stuff but you've always
been a comic who's funny period you do
blue material but it's it's not a crutch
for you and I say that genuinely because
I do as someone who worked pretty clean
there are some people where you take it
away
they have no act that's not the case
with you but I really do think that like
what Trevor Noah is talking about and
you see this with a lot of comedians
what sometimes is blue or they they do
they create this edgy act he's really
carefully crafted to seem edgy and
offensive and you go through it you go
one second nothing they said was unsafe
at all they just use some naughty words
but nothing was really offensive as a
premise do you do you feel like you see
that sometimes sometimes it's
disingenuous yeah kind of create dragons
of paper and then slaying them like he's
some truth teller yeah right it's
nonsense
you know what is considered edgy changes
like 50 years ago like the Catholic
Church and religion they ruin living
groups because he made fun of the church
brain
they kill them for career-wise they kill
them you got arrested that's no longer
dangerous you cannot make fun of the
church you can do like certain pedophile
priests jokes it's okay
but now Islam is a sacred cow or
homosexuality or trans issues and in 10
years that won't be the sacred cow 20
years that won't be the sacred cow it'll
be a new thing we don't like people
making fun of blonds watch my blonde
eyebrows
whatever the never boob feels like
they've been oppressed and maybe even
justify yourself yeah that lead the
group and this whole notion of punching
up and punching down can the people can
stop it we doin company you're throwing
punches yes sir
there's no up and down it's a circular
thing some people are funny if some are
behind you summer to the side up and you
just try to hit anything that you think
it's fun
well I think it's an unholy marrying of
you know we've talked about this my
friend bill Whittle has talked about
this the left inherently supports the
underdog even if the underdog is morally
reprehensible so it's like okay we have
to support gays right now because gay
marriage of the underdog got it okay
hold on but now we have to support Islam
because Islam so okay got it
well now we have to support this Muslim
who wants to hang gay people because
it's an impression Olympics or we well
now we have to say there give me more
black people in Game of Thrones because
there's not enough and they inherently
have to support the underdog to the
point where in comedy that means that
you can no longer make fun of whoever
they see as the underdog whoever they
see is the oppressed class of the day
and that really limits it and the
problem that I have with it is not that
someone has an opinion like that but
when they want to establish it as rules
for entertainment that we've never
agreed to yes it's also typically
well-meaning white people who do it like
if you're a white guy and you're talking
about black people and you're saying
something about black people they don't
think white people know they love it
black people are made it compressed well
well if they were an unbreakable
literally
well they yeah that was Samuel Jackson
he was mr. glass it was the worst
villain ever
he had no superpowers he just broke like
glass I was like oh so he's like hyper
intelligent you look not oh he just he's
just a glass man Trane's joke about
Caitlyn Jenner and yeah
I got it wasn't even a nasty job but I
got all these trans people send your
transphobic and I'm like louder Google
must be probably and then one trans
comic said it really well that she used
that example
she said why are people coming to our
aid we're not made out of glass we're
not gonna break if somebody makes a joke
there's a Jamie price she's a comedian
smart state and that was a really great
way to put it it's like people think
that like by making a joke then all of a
sudden you're attacking in your intent
is phishing it's like no no sometimes I
just make an observation about somebody
or a joke about the person it doesn't
mean you're oppressing them shaking them
screaming balance and they're annoying
you do the new Europe face again it's
like when you get mad at ya you realize
I don't have to do these yo-yo diets and
this method acting I'll just do this um
you know we just had to and Benjamin and
I don't know if you've ever worked with
with Owen at all more of a Los Angeles
comedian but you know he's uh I mean an
amazing comedian you know did a lot of
work with Adam Sandler the happy madison
crew but was kind of seen as that sort
of quintessential la comic you know
goofy he's a master Pete pianists like
he's been playing classical piano for a
long time so but now if you watch him he
is more conservative we have him on the
show a lot now he would not be
considered edgy in the sense that he's
never been a super offensive comedian
but now he's experienced it he's
experienced people walking out because
he's made a Caitlyn Jenner joke or
walking out because he's talking about
you know safe spaces or college campuses
and it's turned him and I wonder if a
lot of people like Trevor Noah
or some other extent some other
comedians who are left they've never
actually fought it's kind of like you
know you talk about jiu-jitsu or MMA
everyone has their theories nosecone
I've got this Tiger Claw and I know I
know how the world works how combat
works and then all of a sudden they get
hit once they oh oh I really don't know
what this world is like I don't think
until you step out and actually take
that risk and talk about the things
people like Trevor no I don't want you
to talk about that they can know and do
you think a vibe maybe just a it's a
symptom of them being so insulated
because do you think anyone in Trevor
Noah's set says hey hold on a second
you're wrong about this
you think that ever happens I don't I
probably not on any set were to John
Oliver or to yeah John there one or any
other one doing a sex usually the crew
is going to nod at you but Trevor again
I say he comes from a unique place like
where did it come like he comes from a
place to really be legitimately he saw
the stuff that we read about from the
50s the 40s
a lot of that so he comes over and he
has a bias even if I don't agree with
them but I defended him when he got in
trouble yeah I was Jewish jokes I was
like well the guy's a comedian just
tweeting jokes whether or not they were
stupid or inappropriate okay but there
are people that want to yank his job
yeah yeah and I'm like he's first of all
she's good for Comedy Central we're
sticking with it yeah again this guy
comes from this place where he has seen
really being treated horribly and then
he makes this joke and a bunch of guilty
white people in our country are gonna go
Oh shame on you little man yeah you know
just silly and it's like I like Trevor I
don't think he should be rooting for
people to get boycotted Rob because
again what affects people now is very
arbitrary and it changes well there you
go so we'll give Trevor Noah a pass on
that rich white liberal America what's
your Excuse
we have to go Tim Norton mouth full of
shame on Netflix watch it the Jim Norton
and Sam Roberts on XM it's also
available to podcast right yes and we're
on channel 103 across the board on
Sirius XM every day on channel 103 thank
you so much Tim we'll have you back on
so we have Oh Clint Howard is he under
lying eyes
[Music]
don't call it a tumblr it's an actual
mug in hand etched girthy campfire mug
it actually fits just as much as most
tumblers lot of you won't realize in
porcelain is actually still a great
choice you know it's old-fashioned it's
old-fashioned but it's gonna be around
for a while accept it you know who you
are who we're talking to a lot of credit
outcome slash mug Club thank you guys so
much we you know what to kind of give
you some context we talked about how
we're being threatened with a lawsuit by
a famous estate for some videos that
we've done and they're not really happy
about it we're going to fight it we
can't discuss exactly what it is right
now
we'll have bill Richman on soon but
guess what that's what mug Club supports
mug club not we went out we met with
YouTube and we haven't had a lot of
answers we've been playing nice but
until we get some of the issues resolved
15 we found out 15 out of 16 or 19
videos on our YouTube channel are in
restricted mode without mug club we're
not able to fight back because they
strip you of your revenue Facebook
YouTube they strip you of your revenue
they stripped you of your audience they
make it really hard for you to subscribe
and when you join for 99 dollars
annually 69 if you're student veteran
active military it allows us to keep a
direct line of communication with you
and no matter what these social media
ghettos do we can keep everyone here
employed Jared Edward Courtney Casey
Aaron the intern Matt Brautigan there's
so many people thank you to everyone
it's about a dozen people now who are
employed because you joined Mudd Club
they make good incomes they don't even
need to sit in a corner fighting for 15
working for Soros because we actually
pay them significantly more than that
and of course when you join you get the
full daily show you can try it for seven
days free by the way if you don't like
it 7 days free try it you get morning
grinders and the rest of the see our TV
lineup and we're putting out more free
content than ever because we want to be
the thorn in Facebook and YouTube side
we want to invite the people who
threatened to sue us because we've done
a video that they've declared offensive
and a violation of their trademark which
it isn't we'll talk about that next week
we want to invite them to court and
thank them for the gift of fighting with
free speech but we can't do it unless
you're joined Adil's better dot-com /
mark club so I leave the choice to you
[Music]
[Applause]
hey there handsome
no not not you Oh Lord no I'm talking
about that snazzy t-shirt looks like
someone's been dropping some coin at
louder with grotto shop calm now come
near let the world see don't be shy
there we go that's what I'm talking
about oh no someone's trying to be a
sneaky fellow
let's go we're that bad boy loud and
proud nothing to be ashamed of here hey
what's the big idea stop kidding around
and show everybody your swag don't make
me come down there well now your t-shirt
just says socialism which is far more
embarrassing there we go see nothing to
be afraid of available exclusively
louder with Crowder shop calm mug
clubbers are almost never beaten up for
wearing a long-sleeve socialism is for
[ __ ] t-shirt unless of course you're
sickly looking and lacking
self-confidence and that's why we now
sell long-sleeve versions perfect for
those cool summer nights and covering up
a lifetime of Jim avoidance and for
decisions get yours now at lardo with
greater shop comm that's louder with
greater shop comm because anywhere else
would be pure factory
[Applause]
[Music]
alright good have our next guest because
you never know what will happen
one of the most oh look there we go look
he got his own mug club look at that
hopefully it enhances it with Co D I
don't know I don't quite get it okay so
before before you came on it Clint
Howard by the way people who don't know
Clint Howard legendary film actor and
you look like you're about to go into a
boxing ring we were just talking about
this during the break what what is what
is this you show up like a pimp this is
sort of special actually I'm screwing
around today and if I had if I told you
I'd have to kill you so just but I'm
screwing around and and I'm trying to
mix in a sauna hmm oh you're doing a
plug for yourself - I like it
I just actually drink the mug cause it's
just so girthy and hand - no so anyway I
have I'm gonna go to the sauna and on
special occasions I break out this
wonderful swag gift that Jim Carrey got
all the cast and crew members for being
in the grinch
back in the heyday of the big movies I
got some great swag Russell Crowe dug
deep and got a really nice like leather
jacket and and this is Jim Carrey his
central humor he got us all a robe I
don't know you know I don't know whether
you can see this or not oh I can see
that is it now is that terry cloth or is
it police yeah no no it's the real deal
it's really nice this is before they
quit giving people a huge amounts of
money to be in movies well ha we still
hear about these crazy salaries so it
seems like there's still some money but
you're just overall less it's it's what
what's happening is is there are there
are very few people that can command the
top tier paycheck no okay for a while
there was oh I don't know I there was a
dozen mm-hmm there was it probably more
and now you really have to prove to the
studios that you are the bomb right
there
yeah and they'll pay you yeah but other
than that they quit sending their
airplanes for people
pretty quickly well you guys finally
bring it because four years actually for
years Vince Vaughn was dollar per dollar
the best investment in Hollywood and you
know he came out of the closet is much
more conservative he's been very open
about it and after that ya could not get
a good review for any film now I know
he's done some bad films but there's
some films that he's done that were
pretty good that we're getting zero you
know a lot in tomatoes or 15% and I know
yeah it's sad I know Vince cuz I worked
with him on the dilemma that's right
yeah
and he is he he he told me some stuff I
mean you know really good like advice
and ideas about surviving in the
business I have a feeling he knew what
was coming as far as getting picked on
by you know the liberal media yeah and
listen I thought first of all I thought
Vince was great I thought Vince was was
really creative and we had a great time
working together it I don't know you
know some of that you bring on yourself
as far as the bad bad press or at least
negative vibes yeah from the press right
and you know thank goodness hey Vince
made his dough you know it there are
people that will complain about all my
careers in a downturn yeah but you've
made 80 million dollars yeah yeah
example he's off in his own compound to
think in Montana or something and Owen
Benjamin who's just in the show but
produced with him in a TV series and
said the same thing he just he just is
not interested in in the I guess sort of
the pageantry of it anymore
yeah listen if you don't really have to
play the game you have a choice I mean
it still is America isn't it I mean you
know we have a constitutional right to
pursue happiness Hey and I was gonna ask
you I was gonna ask it it was just it's
just recent news obviously your brother
directing the Han Solo spin-off can you
can we expect Clint Howard in the Star
Wars universe in any capacity you know
the only thing you can expect is a huge
lawsuit if I said anything come on we're
trying this is also news we're trying to
get a scoop here Clint you show up with
your chest you're distractin scoop you
can scoop to you empty my cat box
nobody cast you have items' attitude
well probably probably 12 pages is what
I've heard I'll do I'll do a president
Trump somebody told me that I said the
most ridiculous thing he's like giving
himself not just deniability but it's 30
he's admitting he's talking third hand
about himself yes but I've heard that
people have told me if I was to get a
job he would probably come with about a
12 page writer in terms of security and
and and they're right at bad right you
know approval of anything outside of
ingestion error well I hope to see you
in there obviously because you've been
in I mean you've been in so many iconic
roles it would be awesome to see you be
and part one of the most iconic film
franchises my dad's I tell you what did
I'll tell you something I was I I
auditioned for the original Star Wars as
who well you know I probably Luke
Skywalker
I remember seeing Mark Hamill well how
do you not remember who you read for
well it was you gotta remember in those
days the initial auditions were they
were seeing everybody and it didn't
really matter right what you read it
wasn't like today's world when you go in
for an audition they have you read every
line of dialogue in the sitcom right
you're saying yeah it's like how can you
prepare that in two days but so they
gave me something to do a little
something to do I couldn't tell what it
was
there was Francis Coppola in the room
there was a fellow named Gino havens in
the room and I was about 18 years old I
was scared as all get-out and I saw mark
mark was nervously pacing learning
looking at the lines mhm and George was
in his director's chair not a director's
chairs in a big leather chair behind and
he was spun around and he turned around
to face me and he went Commander Baylock
korbinite maneuver and I the last thing
I wanted to hear was some childhood
reference no offense to George but in my
mind I'm just going
get a life you know I got Francis
Coppola sitting over here why it'll eyes
at myself and George is asking me about
commander Baylock korbinite maneuver
from Star Trek well let you know I won't
see when I was come to find out that
Star Trek geeks have a tremendous
earning capability and they've learned
well well cuz I've gone to a couple of
Star Trek conventions and boy just
bang-up bang-up business I was going
well I don't know if you'll be mad for
me to ask this next question my dad
wanted me to ask you because we've done
sketches with hopper my dog out here and
you know the rules don't work with
children and animals so obviously
working with a bear for 70 have any
story said anything happened with the
bear or maybe someone got mauled or
something went wrong cuz with hopper
he'll just run over somebody but a bear
you know you're dead well yeah bear
you're not dead they've got guys
standing by you know and also first of
all that kind of bear would not eat meat
they proved it to me right away they
threw in a piece of raw meat and the
bear sniffed it it didn't go for it and
then they threw in a box of doughnuts
and the bear ate it in about five
seconds what about well just to worry
hipsters they're like 99% vegetarian
yeah per digit seniors they oh no the
bear could just eat circles around any
of these new you know this new
generation this bear would eat like 24
loaves of bread a day bags a monkey chow
a dozen heads of lettuce a bunch of
bushes and bushels of not bushels but
things are carrots they tried to have
voters have a well-balanced diet
although the bear like to drink Pepsi
Cola or coca-cola they did a trick where
the bear would you know the bear would
hold up the coke so the bear ate a lot
and the bear was big I got sat on once
you were no large don't you laugh have
you ever been sat on my bear
no no frigging is scary so you know
alright I have no I'm gonna man was hot
it was hot and the bear was tired and I
was jerking on his change is one too
many times have my passenger tap
yeah and the bear just turned around and
he he mauled me you're not bald me he
like got me with his with his mouth but
he didn't have any front teeth so it was
just a matter of pressure was a mighty
humble dummy in it it scared me yeah I'm
and the animal trainers were in there to
pull the bear away the bear wasn't me no
bear was just mad yeah and that was
scary one time the worst thing that
happened was the raccoon
we had a baby raccoon named Charlie it
was a pet in the series and Charlie was
I was supposed to come to me and I'm
supposed to pick Charlie up in a shot
and we did it a few times in fact we did
it one too many times
Charlie got used to the behavior and
instead of allowing me to pick him up
Charlie just beat me to it and he just
climbed me and I had a little terry
cloth shirt on all right I mean just a
little cotton shirt and it was the most
painful thing I've ever felt in my life
because this raccoon they have to have
their claws yeah because they eat with
their claws it was like a cat with with
their claws extended climbing me and you
know the day's shooting was over and I
went to the hospital and the next day
the Wardrobe woman Peggy Kunkle she had
a leather vest made for me that I can
wear underneath my shirt and I thought
well that's great Peggy where were you
yesterday yeah and then you could wear
that leather vest to street parties in
San Francisco so we can we expect any
upcoming stories of maybe being mauled
by wookies or sat on by by Ewoks yes it
could that be in the future
he walks well you know what yeah listen
I kid
I'll neither confirm nor deny I'm even
alive at this point dammit Clint Howard
I'm not sure where I'm gonna be working
on next but you know what things are
looking really good I'm I'm I'm working
I've been doing some writing I've got
this project that I feel like has a lot
of validity and and you know my
brother's been busy
uh-oh we lost I don't even know is
calling in just tell them no hang on
sorry
tell them no there you go this is okay
this is the Wonder Nemedia this is the
show hey let me ask you this have you
been following do you follow awards at
all anymore the Emmys did you see the
announced list
oh my god it would take you about an
hour to go through the lit was that
nominees for best you know fluffer and
stuff well we were talking about this I
think this year you know Emmys the worst
rated year ever for them last year and
they've really overreached when we talk
about far-left they nominated Bill Nye
for his sex spectrum episode which was
so bad it was so bad we just ran the
video on the show and laughed you know
they were rapping about but junk in 57
genders and it's like and Bill Nye
seriously he's good he's nominated he'll
win Gore up for anything I'm sorry I
didn't comb over the list really
carefully right is Al did it is it I
don't think so hissy well he's sick well
isn't out yet so he I don't think it is
in um except to I mean we're here even
when they're going for the Academy
that's Grammy material they're now
rosters he's nominated for an Emmy and
you know Ron and I certainly sit on
different sides of the dinner table but
he's nominated for me you know my
brother ruff won a Grammy
well I'm sorry so I would quit he's way
on well why cuz it piss you off you
should be happy for your brother Clint
because because see I had a band when I
was in my early twenties and and and you
know I actually had a I have an inkling
of an artistic creative kind of skill
sure a musical round yeah Ron is a
basket case when it comes to music he
just is he does he he can play the
guitar and at times he's been inspired
but one of his weaknesses as a filmmaker
is he doesn't really connect music to
the image right and yet he did the
Beatles documentary and listen he
directed it he had a lot of people
helping him and the fact that he won an
Emmy for that just I mean not an Emmy a
Grammy Grammy the fact that he's got his
Grammy sitting there and it's like that
could be Stevie Wonder David Bowie or
Clint Howard yes Ron Howard and you know
what it's maybe it's bad karma
I shouldn't have urinated on him when I
was
maybe I'm still paying the price I think
the only way to counter balance is to
urinate on his grandma get it Romana
Grande steal it and then next time I
want to see that on your shelf but you
know what I'd have to i'd have to
somehow distract him get him away from
it for a few minutes well and oh thank
well both of us do it here's what we'll
do we'll issue a press release claiming
that you revealed confidential star
wars' information he'll come out to beat
us up while he's gone you steal his
Grammy have you ever heard about anybody
urinating down somebody's windpipe
because that's what would happen to you
no one could say they didn't see it
coming
I hope it's warm there and you can enjoy
a nice cool cool drink all right well I
need to talk to much about the Emmys but
it's always a pleasure to have Clint
Howard on clip we'll get we'll get the
the Skype stuff working next time so we
can do a little more but go enjoy your
sauna take off the robe and have fun
hey not until I get to the sauna
otherwise I get arrested well let your
freak flag fly your celebrity anytime
man any time thanks Clint have a good
one we'll be back okay
[Music]
what you know I'm trying to watch my
grammar I bought this month watch daily
you know won't get my money learn I do
it after knocking dad faces a story on
rubra want to put them titties a good
news man
it's what you were made to do Josephine
vector domain I wish I could help you
what I plan when it sounds reviving
victims she stops it [ __ ] you know we're
always do
[Music]
[Music]
right with you apparently other than the
sound guys checked out but great thank
you very much - uh - Clint Howard the
air again stopped working in here the
air conditioning was working we told you
weather that we had problems with it in
our studio and then it worked and then
it stopped so we brought in the air and
it worked while the air guy was here
then a little bit I know I'm gonna know
it's summer it's summer yeah it is very
very hot and that really that really
grinds my gears and someone comes over
well unless you can replicate the
mistake right now like when you go to
the Apple store my phone just sometimes
just freezes for no well it's not frozen
now oh great
maybe you can solve the problem while
I'm walking out with my new phone would
you like to speak to our genius now how
about customer service yeah yeah took a
weekend course in the iPad you're not a
member of Mensa
thanks so much that I guess we would the
theme this week for those who aren't mug
Club members we've been talking about I
don't know how many times we've used the
phrase it's time from Chris Hemsworth
John boyega I think Caitlyn Jenner in
the view there are at least three or
four stories that people saying it's
time for X it's time for female
president it's time for black people on
Game of Thrones it's time for Game of
Thrones the creative slave dunkirk it's
time for female James Bond this is the
mantra right now it's time what's crazy
is not get your now we're talking about
this
it seems really nonsensical but when you
when you break it down you can
understand why the it's time is such a
commonly used phrase when we were
growing up you know it's it's time to
learn these lessons I mean my dad would
say well it's time to grow up son or you
know it's it's time to time to learn
from your mistakes or it's time it
started with it's time to wipe your own
posterior yes time to wipe your own butt
and then it's like hey time to dress
yourself time to dress yourself now it's
time to get a job it's time to pay for
your own school so there was a point
where it's time when someone would say
there was usually a moment and what it
usually involved was it's time to insert
moral action here or action period here
definitive action here proactive action
here or it's time for personal spiritual
emotional physical development that's
what it was swimming and zooming a new
responsibility right it's these were
it's time
for to assuming personal responsible
it's time to develop it's time to evolve
and that's how we're all raised that's
basically what schooling was why it's
third grade it's time to learn long
division maybe that was fourth grade
it's eighth grade time to learn
trigonometry that is what it's time
meant in the left now we'll never do
that right they avoid that like the
plague
but is it oh okay so do you mean it's
time what we're talking about the black
community being underrepresented is it
time for the black community to get a
movement involved where dads stay in the
household well no no it's not time for
that is it time for kids to pay for
their own school no no it's not is it
time for women now that they're
independent to purchase their own birth
control no no is it time for people to
be responsible parents is it time for
parents to make moral judgments and
knowing how to raise their children is
it time for us to make black-and-white
moral decisions regarding our political
economic future no no no no no oh what
do you mean it's time for a female James
Bond
oh you just say it's time because it's
something that we haven't seen before
and what does that do that assumes that
there's something inherently morally
virtuous if it's something that you have
an experience yeah right we're always
will broaden your horizons and that's
true there's a lot of good in there sure
but not always no not always no no I
haven't eaten the poisonous portion of a
pufferfish now it's time during vacation
I was traveling Aruba and one of the
options was to have a layover in Mexico
City I've never done that before it was
not time it was not time before was that
a horizon I wanted to be expanded well
it's because right now we live in an era
where we've been told for so long and
it's swinging back the other way I'm
excited about that there is no right
there is no wrong it's situational
ethics right so you can't say it's time
to father up it's time to marry the girl
because you knocked her up it's time to
provide for your family because you're
the man and head of household we can't
do that so it's just it's time for I
don't know what have we not seen before
and they want to draw the equivalency
that the first is equivalent to some
actual accomplishment the first black
president is equivalent to the first
great president the first female
president is the equivalent to
the first president who I don't know
actually follows through on their
promises the first female James Bond is
the equivalent to the most popular James
Bond the most widely widely viewed as
success critically beyond I think 99%
yeah yeah Rotten Tomatoes James Bond
it's it's time for black people on Game
of Thrones is the equivalent to man the
writings really good on Game of Thrones
it's time because it's the first is
their moral equivalency - it's time to
get better and that's where you're
seeing this now it's the same you've
kind of see it's the same enclave of
people culturally who don't want red
pens on tests they don't want someone to
win a soccer game Owen was singing about
that earlier this is that generation so
this generation where they don't they
don't believe in themselves they don't
believe in resting on the laurels of
their accomplishments it's got to be
something else so I know and what I
don't have to be an accomplishment
doesn't necessarily have to be something
that's actually any benefit society but
by god it'll be the first because it's
time you know what it's time to actually
go back to judging people based on their
merits how about that it's time to go
back to a meritocracy it's time to
handle your own crap and take some
personal responsibility it's time to
stop saying it's time and I hate you
I'll see you next week
[Music]